all of our still sports will be
relocating to Manhattan we want to take
it to the world but we're trying to take
this site and crank it the what an
idiot
the finer things Club the scumbag club
you are cute are you men America the
game stop sending the dicks
we're fun your father better prettier
than everybody else who's stealing our
stick on the Internet I said work five
work we would tear this city apart of
you're a loser
and I'm gonna make you a winner you
can't do live TV Biff cores muffin and I
tried to eat it I was like I open my
mouth as I was coming in you gotta get
in the mirror
I'd be better at my game oh hey Adele
we're coming
we're not stopping you think we're
getting smaller getting bigger I'm gonna
be in your ear everywhere you can find
us
you